I I think the the biggest skill set
missing in America right now is
listening
uh empathetic listening seems to have
disappeared you know
um we're now at the point where I'm
right you're wrong on both sides and on
anything
um and learning to understand the point
of view of another human being I think
is vital
um and it's and it's a skill set we
don't teach and it's a skill set we
don't practice and it's the it's the
skill that creates common bond that
allows us to find common cause it's the
skill that allows us to make progress
um and uh and we don't practice it as a
population
as well as we could
um and and then we look at our politics
and our politics I think reflect our
society not the other way around